no I i'm interested in butte beauty as a
byproduct of a thought of important
thought of critical thought and I I
think maybe when I was younger I was
more interested in this very willful
creation of beauty trying to make
something beautiful but I'm less and
less interested in that and i and I
think all any beauty that comes out in
my work is just a byproduct of of some
rigorous development of work that
responds to the world that we're in and
I feel like the more honest and earnest
and that that work is the more innately
beautiful it will be without me having
to get too involved with it I think
there's certain decisions that I make
obviously they're very they're very
aesthetic and that are very like um you
know very carefully considered aesthetic
decisions about what things will look
like but um but I try not to get too
much in the way of that I kind of let
things evolve the way they need to in
and I think um hopefully a byproduct
will be beauty I know Buckminster Fuller
actually who's another here of mine he
has this wonderful filmed lecture at
this architecture school where he's
screaming at all these architects like
why they're trying to make everything so
beautiful not understanding that if they
design things that were in keeping with
the basic principles of nature
everything that they made would innately
be beautiful because it was part of
those eternal truths which is kind of
easy to say but I on some level I think
it's true if you look at his work there
are very few willfully beautiful moments
but everything that he did is so
gorgeous just out of these kind of
intricate systems that he created and
that were responding to natural forces
and systems that he observed all around
him